i just want to reassure you this isn't
about blame
it's about using what happened to all of
us this
thing we all just lived through those of
us who did live through it
it's about using it as a teaching moment
i've always hated that phrase me too
[Music]
basically you're not on trial your
company is one of many nationwide who
signed up to this
project to map basic human behaviors
during the pandemic both
you know academia research also to help
us plan for future crises using all the
uh
sorry us being oh just your average
software enterprise company
one of the many private firms contracted
during the crisis to
help the government in gathering data to
inform policy
to find the worst lockdown offenders you
mean you're trying to pinpoint who's
most responsible
uh that's one way of looking at it
what's the other way of looking at it
who was most irresponsible
how was it for you how is my existential
dystopia
yeah is that right how was yours
yeah well my fiancee decided to ride the
last one out with his sick mum so
you know not amazing amazing but fine
the third british lockdown came into
force on 6th of january
2021 you began working from home
you're a barrister
junior four years called family law
cool well like a lot of firms you all
installed software to monitor when
people were away from their desks
you were pretty consistent at first but
then your patterns started
to um
change did they yeah
yeah that first week your smartwatch
recorded you going on a nice run at
seven every morning
wait you have that 4k which took you an
average of
21 minutes not bad but then from january
the 18th onwards you stopped
that routine and you started to leave
the house
at night instead
which is still okay it's just is it okay
because it feels like i might be being
made to feel like it's not
okay like i said this is not about
judgment
it's about patterns
you live with your fiance jason and you
rent a spare room to
allison you got my housemate's name from
my smartwatch
your cohabitant's names are in the local
authorities database
our firm has partnered up with many
different bodies
as part of our work to
collate both public and private
consumer data yeah it's just this is
starting to feel like an interrogation
only
you're not the police it's not an
interrogation
although we have partnered with the
police and actually
actually this isn't me being but um
the police now come to software
companies like us for intel
not the other way around
to the evening of january the 19th then
you
left the house in non-running gear
without your smartwatch or your
smartphone
almost um
almost like i don't know like you
didn't want to be tracked yet you were
tracking me and no one was tracking you
then this is retrospective historic data
how'd you know i wasn't wearing my smart
watch a door can i don't have a door cam
you don't have a door cam but your
neighbor has one a ring door can it
caught you
ring just gave you access to any
the police partnered with ring we
partnered with the police look the point
is rachel can i ask you where you went
and why
just for this study that's all we didn't
pick you up via any facial recognition
on cctv
probably because you were wearing a mask
very good although i'm not gonna lie
that has been a bit of a nightmare
in my field let me tell you i have no
idea what
who the hell remembers this stuff you
repeated these little
jaunts uh for about a week
sometimes with your smartwatch on now
maybe if you got to take it off
easily done uh you went
to roughly this location
what was that who was there
you know what i think i think
you missed your fiance
do you i think this was an extraordinary
traumatic time and it was hard
the real world was shuttered up leaving
only the digital world and its offer of
new
[Music]
temptations i'm not a psychologist or a
sociologist
i'm an analyst but judging by the data
and
frankly my own personal
observations i think the boundaries were
crossed by many of us by most of us
understandably
even the prudish brits with messages
that become
images that become videos that become
live videos
[Music]
are hidden fantasies and
exposed faces even though we vaguely
know deep down that these images we send
they're not going
straight to that other person's device
even though that's what it feels like
you know
intimate one-to-one connection no
they're instead being
handed over to a tech company to store
on a server that's probably in a
different country with different laws
where it will sit
possibly forever we know that but
we're also only human
[Music]
i think it's also because the home
changed too didn't it literally the
nature of what the home had been for
centuries gone within weeks
from a private place
sanctuary to a public space of work
and we were forced to welcome anyone and
everyone into it through a screen but i
i didn't send anything to
jason oh are you really sitting here
suggesting i betrayed my
my fiance we know you started to develop
huge feelings of anxiety
and guilt about something
okay you can read all the location
settings and data sets you like you
can't get inside
my head my heart actually
when you return home from that first
evening away from the house
your smart home thermostat registered
you
showering for a full 20 minutes
trying to wash something away excuse me
that night and
many nights following you had a deeply
restless sleep
you asked alexa to list covered symptoms
on the morning of the 21st at 9
34 and alexa returned results to you
from the nhs website that could have
been my housemate it was your voice and
by the way your alexa your echo your
siri your google doc
they are always listening why i wonder
did you have to check symptoms if you
hadn't been close to anyone outside your
house
and why were you googling questions
around forgiveness rachel at 3am in the
morning
how to forgive can you forgive someone
who hurt you jesus christ this is some
stasi level and then of course the
contact tracing app which all beautiful
citizens downloaded
well that tells us that you were in the
presence of someone who also had the app
for sustained periods a man
who wasn't your fiance a man
who when you were in his company that
first night that you were in his
physical proximity
your heartbeat went up
and up and
up so you see it is possible to see into
your heart
maybe even to see what you refuse to
acknowledge yourself
i no longer consent this is beyond the
remit you have no right
right we are trying to understand what
motivated people to break the
restrictions and if it's intentionally
breaking if it's love
or lust or fear or anything we have to
plan to mitigate these human flaws coded
into us
feelings that make us act against our
own best interest and the interest
of those around us i mean was it us is
there something in our national parking
around
people without any right highest
infection rates in the world why us
why in the third wave was there a spike
of infections in your area
who was that who was the patient zero of
this story whose behavior
started this spread have you ever seen
those maps in school books of how the
great fire of london broke out and
spread
everything future school children
studying the great pandemic of 2020
you're going to be able to draw their
own
you're blaming normal people of
person-to-person contact we have it all
it's all stored every human interaction
ever spread of misinformation
who's the typhoid mary of this story
responsible for all those extra deaths
responsible for the pain of losing
someone of not being able to visit your
your father in hospital but to say
goodbye to him over a phone
instead as you hear his last breaths
ebbing away over a
[ __ ] speakerphone
apple reminder to stand and breathe
[Music]
[Music]
so so i know i specialize in family law
not
whatever this is oh i think
no i think citizens have the right to
express some
or some unease at the way during a
pandemic
technology companies rode in to help
governments all over the world often
free of charge to collate and gain
access to citizen data
to beat a virus with little scrutiny or
oversight where was the vote the public
consultation in letting
amazon pair with the nhs a private
company our health data
but that's the point isn't it about
algorithms no one really knows how they
work
even though in an increasingly automated
world ai is making decisions for us
all the time what our insurance premium
should be
or a-level results or predictive
policing or even
prison sentencing and release all of it
and accountable is it accountable
what if say say i had a friend that had
a daughter that lived in a residential
street that one day
a max application discovered was quiet
and redirected cars down it to avoid
a build-up of traffic elsewhere and my
friend's daughter
she she runs out into the road because
it was quiet yesterday so she thinks
it's going to be quiet today
and she's knocked down and she's killed
and my friend wants justice but it is
denied to her because you cannot take an
algorithm
to court okay what we do know
about these so-called digital gods
playing with our lives is that
unlike what you said earlier they do
contain all the human flaws of the
people who coded and created them
was it katie o'neill cathy o'neil who
said
algorithms are simply opinions embedded
in code
facial technology didn't pick up my face
because of my mask all because it's up
to 40 less effective
at recognizing black women than white
men and you're asking me
to submit myself to the infallibility of
a system that doesn't allow anyone to
pop open the hood and take a look inside
i
i do not submit myself to it to any of
it not everything can be known
from data people are individual we are
complex
you blame the government in outsourcing
its decisions to date companies like
ours
you outsource every day of your life
you're like this so try that
where to eat what to watch you you found
your fiance
on a dating app you outsourced your love
oh pick me someone pick me you handed
over your own human agency so
nice speech but most people very
willingly during that pandemic
sacrificed a few very outdated notions
of privacy so that the algorithms could
do
what people couldn't track the virus and
save lives and i know that you'd like to
think that everyone's an individual but
you're not
i'm not i fall into a predictable
pattern of behaviors based on 100
different data points based on my race
my age my class the things i watch you
think you won in a million
congratulations on a planet of 8 billion
that means there are more than 8
000 people exactly like you did
you break the restrictions because of a
relationship with this man all you can
measure is what people do you can't know
why
there is no why good enough did you did
you have an affair with joe
a man whose facebook profile you clicked
on 28 times in 24 hours
a man who went on to contract i don't
trust this but not because not because
your algorithms are
good enough because they're too good i
mean imagine imagine can you
imagine a social media platform so good
i recommended to you people that you may
know
that it recommends you are out of
nowhere when you're nowhere near ready
the man who sexually and emotionally
abused you over many months and years
who during your relationship gaslit and
tormented and manipulated you and yet
you somehow managed to extricate
yourself from to survive
only to be faced with the face of that
person you've been trying to forget
people you may know i'll [ __ ] say
and where was my control where was my
agency
that's
that's who you uh you went to see
why to confront him i think you'll know
how you'll react i still under the
guidelines
based on previous behaviors you did this
so you'll likely do that
you think you'll want some sort of you
know justice
revenge but when you're into their world
when you
read what they're writing see them
struggling i mean
like we all were posting thoughts about
ending it all and seeing no one come to
their aid well
sometimes you can surprise even yourself
perhaps the way to move on from
something done by someone perhaps
helping
to save that person might just be the
most surprising way of surviving that
thing yourself
how to forgive
people are unpredictable
possibly but viruses aren't
i'll note for the record that you made
a personal decision
to break the restrictions to
possibly
save a life but i'm sorry that may have
killed 20 more by transmitting the virus
and that's why the data knows best and
that's why we
must hand ourselves over to it as
emotional beings
we are simply unable to measure that
equivalence ourselves
so
[Music]
your audit trail go into the system and
an automated verdict delivered to you in
due course
will i be able to appeal yeah of course
although the outcome will be the same
algorithms they
don't tend to change their minds
would you like an uber home
recommended i walk
well if that's what it recommends
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you